slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy it's also an incredible way to
transform meat into mouth-wateringly
melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks to
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity
slice alongside the bone straight down
you can see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start coloring that in
[Music]
it's really important to
give the beef short rib a really nice
sear
if you didn't brown the meat off
it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a
heaped teaspoon of tomato
just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it
cooking out that smell of puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she
goes great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish it's a light cured pancetta
we want nice thick lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not going to slice them
i'm just going to cut them in half
but look at the colour on those lardons
now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon
mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp another
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift
and place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
all that nice
pureed garlic coming through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor
scrape
all of that off the sieve
nice
then
just start
sieving all that lovely brazing liquor
wow
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on your bacon
and your mushrooms
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine in freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces when you need to chill wine fast
simply add a large handful of salt to
your ice bucket the salt reduces the
freezing point of the water which will
chill your wine in six minutes flat
a delicious saffron flatbread with
mussels it doesn't get any healthier
than that first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the color
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil that
makes the dough nice and silky and rich
your saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now sit that in your bowl cover it with
cling film let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'm going to cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
to like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts the
blister
she's ready
for turning
beautiful get the color on there
now you want it nice and crisp
almost blistering on both sides because
it's nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
on to the mussels now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta i want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavor
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes they're just going in
whole the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry i think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor
gotta lock in
that heat the muscles will take four to
five minutes to steam in the meantime
cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely
don't want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy